how do we live so we best fit in with
existing Earth Systems it's going to be
made a lot easier if we can reduce our
total energy consumption the main option
is nuclear unless you have fueled
batteries that's this great big fairy
tale that this is carbon neutral when in
reality it's one of the worst things
that people are doing there's still a
very clear relationship between energy
use and the increase of income ahead
beats me why we should take something
that is dangerous and expensive when
there is something cheap and safe
available instead
[Music]
the thing that we don't talk about
anything like enough is that if we're
going to transition away from fossil
fuels which of course we so urgently
need to do uh it's going to be made a
lot easier if we can reduce our total
energy consumption and that's something
we need to do a lot at the global level
and even more so in countries like this
where we where we can uh where we can
more readily do so uh and that's not
what the fossil fuel companies want uh
that's not the narrative that they want
to have they they talk about how we're
going to meet our Rising energy demands
we have to have a shrinking energy
demand
just to bring a wider context on this
um you know if you look at where
humanity is at at the moment we've been
growing our energy Supply by 2.4 a year
for the last 50 years
um we've been growing our energy supply
for Millennia through our use of energy
and Technology it's brought us lots of
wonderful things but it's also taken to
humanity to a very dangerous place uh
and we are going to need to uh do a lot
of new thinking uh about how we run
Society how we think how what kinds of
things we can grow because it's you know
I'm neutral about whether we grow GDP
but I think it's an irrelevance but we
absolutely it's very dangerous to keep
growing uh our energy Supply well I
think I think the risk of that frankly
is that you end up with a very
unpredictable and nasty Global recession
and I fear that's actually what we're
going to see towards the end of this
year and next year precisely because
you're taking such a large bite out of
people
disposable income and because that means
they're going to curtail their
consumption and consumption
maybe something that's at the margin for
everybody in this tent but actually
consumption for somebody who's on low
incomes and uh Brazil or uh in India or
China is a matter of life or death so
you know I want to try and understand
this deep Green Vision which says we can
actually go back to some world where we
don't use a synthetic fertilizer because
actually I've seen calculations that
suggest that that 8 billion population
would have to come down to four billion
no in order to be sustainable now I've
you know maybe there may be other
calculations that show less but the the
reality is it's going to be a smaller
population so is it you
or is it you
and which politician is going to have
the effectively uh the courage to turn
around and say sorry we're going to be
operating a one-child policy in future
or even a no child policy yeah no it's
not right that we can't feed
um even even 9 or 10 billion people uh
quite happily without I'm not saying no
fertilizer but drastically reducing our
fertilizers we can be more efficient in
the way that we use it by a lot and I
think you your answer that we can also
you know the most important thing uh you
know simple thing in in one sense simple
thing we can do is Reduce by a long way
the amount of meat and dairy in our
diets and the pressure that that will
take off the food and land system not
just uh not just from a climate
perspective but from a feed the world
perspective and from a biodiversity
perspective as well will be enormous we
can do stuff around waste wasting food
less and we can do a lot of stuff around
uh really sort of careful and highly
skilled and not fully scientifically
understood yet but emerging practices
that enable a lot more productivity out
of land with a lot less input and
actually that requires a lot more people
to work on that land
um we we run our agricultural system in
a way that minimizes the people working
on it because that makes it more more
profitable per person at the moment but
actually you know Humanity has got
people coming out of its ears at the
moment and one of the most fundamentally
rewarding ways you could spend your time
is actually to work on that land so we
need more people working the land not
lesser there are all sorts of you know
it's a very complex area but there are
you know a complete revolution of how we
do the food and land system is
absolutely part of this
and if you want one solution it's a
generation for nuclear uh you know the
small modular nuclear reactors I mean
that's what the solution is
I think it's a good point to bring in
Thomas is that the is that the solution
that we should be looking towards and
are there unintended consequences we
should be aware of if that's
um how we're moving
well
um
I think that the currently looks like
climate change is the biggest problem
we're facing but um there's there's
there are lots of new problems we can
create and I it beats me why we should
take something that is dangerous and
expensive when there is something cheap
and safe available instead so I I I I
mean the nuclear industry has had 60
years to to improve its design and every
time they build a new reactor it's a
scandal everybody that builds and the
owners end up suing each other on the
taxpayer the ordinary person ends up
paying an extraordinary bill
um and so so well I mean
I don't think they will be cheap
or a safe but I mean of course we don't
we don't know if they don't exist yet
well the new generation it's not uranium
they use thorium the molten salt
reactors okay they're much less toxic
this can be recycled the environmental
impacts be much slower you can't build
nuclear bombs out of this
um you know the the issue is power
density I mean the whole history of
human and energy consumption has been
toward greater power density and going
back to solar and wind I mean you can't
run industrial economies on these low
density power sources you need a high
density power source and right now
a generation for nuclear power plants
look like our best option
Martin I think you can get quite a large
fraction
um from solar uh if you have a a grid to
carry energy from the sunny South to the
um uh to the less Sunny north and east
west hopefully along the Belton Road to
China to smooth over Peak demands in
different time zones so I think we can
do that the main point is that you need
a base load
um unless you do have a global grid
where you can have things out anyway and
um you need a base low and the main
option is nuclear unless you have huge
batteries enough to store energy for a
long cold calm spell so I think Battery
Technology is the alternative in
principle to nuclear if you want to have
a stable a base load
Judy did you want to come back in
okay yeah the other issue with solar and
wind is the land use
I mean huge
I I saw an image the other day of this
massive solar farm in China that seemed
to cover a whole Mountain okay and what
this does to our ecosystems
um isn't very good all the mining you
know in order to go totally you know for
the batteries and even just for you know
batteries for electric vehicles
I mean if this is greater than the
normal lithium reserves you know just
for right now I mean the minerals
required the resource use required for
this is just astonishing and
but the numbers just don't add up they
don't add up so I don't see how you
could go beyond about 20 percent of the
global power provided by wind and solar
unless there's some astonishing
breakthrough somewhere that's not
currently anticipated this resource
question I think we have quite a lot of
evidence from the there was a very big
debate in of the limits to growth Spirit
there were there were forecasts we were
going to run out of lead in 1997 and and
all kinds of other things that never
happened quite to the country there's
too much lead around in the environment
and I I'm not necessarily that worried
that we will run out to lithium I think
that is a solvable problem or there
would be substitutes and batteries made
out of something else so that I worry
much more about our destruction of
biodiversity through deforestation and
Andrew climate change uh and so
um
I think actually the the dramatic
increase in performance and and decrease
in cost for Renewables is exactly the um
the most encouraging Trend I've seen
um they keep on falling at the Fantastic
rates
um this was always said the nuclear
power to achieve to meet there but that
never happened and but for solar energy
it is happening it is falling very
dramatically in price and of course the
large these Farms but it is it's very
small area of of the planet and I'd like
to say something about this
intermittency issue I mean large parts
of the planet where most people live you
only have to wait for about 12 hours for
the sun to come back and you don't
necessarily uh spend you so much
electricity during the nights so there's
still of course a storage problem
the parts of the world like where I live
we don't see the Sun for six months at a
time and there really is a storage
problem but those parts are very small
actually I mean there's relatively
little people who live in this but
forsaken place where I live and we have
bioenergy we had good insulation we have
hydropower and and low population
density typically in Canada Siberia and
Sweden so there are there are solutions
to that problem as well
[Music]
when you look into these Technologies
none of them actually will do the job
and also they're at least as bad as
fossil fuel some of them are
dramatically worse which ones
are worse absolutely dams are worse uh
23 of the anthropogenic methane produced
is from dams
um it's completely human created well
and it's 23 of it is from dams let's be
clear that's cement yeah right because
it's not the nature of dams it's because
of all the vegetation that is now stuck
under water in the you know they make
that huge sort of fake lake at the top
that's you know the water behind that
and all of the vegetation that's coming
down inside the river uh is now stuck
and it makes layers and layers at the
bottom of the dam and the only way for
it to break down is through it doesn't
use aerobic decomposition it uses
anaerobic decomposition and one of the
byproducts of that is methane and that's
why they've been called methane bombs
and methane factories but they get
counted by Fiat the the nations of the
world just decided we're going to call
this carbon neutral so all these
countries using dams to make electricity
they get to pretend it's this great big
fairy tale that this is carbon neutral
when in reality it's one of the worst
things that people are doing but so hang
on
hardly any new Renewables have come from
Hydro I mean Hydro is the oldest
renewable technology but most of the
obvious Dam places were exploited by the
1970s so the number of times that people
are really looking at Big Dam projects
now I mean they've exhausted the pool so
what we're talking about was Renewables
nowadays is wind solar
biogas biomass geothermal all of those
Technologies and we're going to be
looking at a future where we can put
those together in a complex system which
actually delivers I hope and trust
something similar to the sort of output
that we've got I totally agree it has to
go hand in hand and I think Mike and I
totally agreed on this it's got to go
hand in hand with reducing as much as we
conceivably can primary energy demand
and providing ladders it's not going to
be good enough to turn around to
developing countries and say sorry you
can't do what we've done don't do what
we do do what we say it's not going to
be good enough they could we've got away
with that with mobile phones because you
can have a mobile phone instead of your
landline system but and you can maybe
able to get away with it with rural
electricity systems based on uh solar
energy but you know a lot of developing
countries have now got big cities and
they need big grids and they're going to
have a lot of electricity so you know we
need a solution there that is actually
going to provide them with those zero
carbon ladders and we haven't been
providing that yeah I just want to walk
you through some of the realities of
what it takes to make a solar panel
um so you need a very specific kind of
sand silicon which is already rare it's
being striplined around the world entire
beaches have been destroyed and
creatures have been pushed further and
further toward extinction because that's
where they live and there are 24 islands
in Indonesia that literally no longer
exist because they have been mined to
death all of the sand was taken so
that's number one
number two is that it takes 3000 degrees
Fahrenheit to turn it into the Silicon
metal it's needed for solar panels so
near where I live in Washington state
there's this there's a big Dam the Box
Canyon Dam and there's a smelter they
want to put in just to make silicone for
these kinds of Technologies the the dam
produces 90 megawatts of electricity the
smelter wants 105. and this is a vast
Dam I mean just picture vast Dam
covering this entire River and it's not
enough energy to produce uh what this
smelter would need
so uh and then what the smelter would
produce in exchange is 320 000 tons of
greenhouse gases it would be the fifth
fifth largest producer in the state of
greenhouse gases
um also acid rain 760 tons of sulfur
dioxide and I think 700 tons of nitrous
oxides as well and then alongside that
you have things like that we've never
heard of but I will tell you about them
sulfur hexafluoride is 25
000 times more powerful than carbon
dioxide 25 000 times and it lasts 3 000
years and then there's hexafluorothane
which is 12 000 times more potent than
carbon dioxide and it's 100
anthropogenic the only reason it exists
is because we produce it when we are
making solar panels it lasts 10 000
years in the atmosphere uh people who
live near a similar smelter in Iceland
ended up with Burns in their throats
because the air was so toxic from the
smelter they were told not to go outside
for months they couldn't go outside
without burning their throats
so this is what goes into it and you
know you see all these headlines about
oh it's gotten so much cheaper and we're
all going to be able to afford this well
the only reason it got cheaper is
because production moved from Germany to
China and what they do in China is no
litigation at all they just take these
highly toxic products and they just
spread it across the landscape I mean
there are very obvious ways of dealing
with localized environmental problems
which we have I mean the reason why
Eastern Europe is currently a lot
healthier than it was in 1989 is
precisely because we have applied EU
rules to a lot of the industrial
activity that was going on there now I
don't know about the the particular
circumstances or what the federal or
state rules are uh in the US but acid
rain for example was dealt with by
sulfur scrubbers and you know we've been
phasing that out uh phasing out
coal-fired power stations anyway uh in
Europe so I mean there there are ways of
dealing with those problems without
throwing the baby out with the bath
water and what worries me is that we
don't pay enough attention which believe
me a lot of Voters are certainly going
to pay attention to to the fact that
what we have has nevertheless given us
things which are without any doubt a
benefit so in 1840 which was the first
census in this country the average life
expectancy was 40 years old the average
life expectancy is now over 80 85
slightly longer 87 for women and that's
happened over the space of this
Industrial Age now maybe all of this is
so uh fragile that it's all going to
disappear I don't believe that's the
case I believe that the Ingenuity the
science the technology that we have used
to drive that massive Improvement in
human welfare over the period of the
Industrial Revolution can be used again
how many promises have governments and
corporations made for decades as in what
happened to the Kyoto Protocol what
happened to the Paris agreement I mean
people can say what they want but are
they doing anything no I mean and
I mean
at what point are we going to start
believing this right at what point are
we going to get this is ridiculous like
this is a whole charade where we're
going to have these big conferences
everyone goes to cop you know 30 or
whatever it is like this has to uh you
know whatever it is like it's not
working if you're actually in look at a
graph of a carbon emissions it's just
there's no dent in it right it's only
when we have bad recessions that
actually is any kind of change and in
fact we actually have to reduce carbon
emissions and other greenhouse gas
emissions by like more than seven
percent a year every year till we reach
zero if you want to stay within one half
percent I wrote a column about
um climate change and the need to tackle
it in the guardian first in
1987. and this is an issue which has
gradually been uh kicked around and
kicked around and I have to say the can
has been kicked down the road for so
long uh that
um it's easy to despair about whether
there are political Solutions we've
certainly been getting it wrong so uh
people want to be told that it's easy
and politicians want to take the easy
steps first but as with any major change
it's also important that we take steps
in the right order it's not just a
question of what steps we should take
but that they should be done in the
correct sequence to ensure the smoothest
possible transition and we've also been
getting our steps in the wrong order so
one of the reasons why we are facing a
gas crisis and we're facing a heating
crisis and a cost of living crisis this
year is very simple we didn't look at
the long-term need to cut demand for
heat in our homes now the coalition
government did many things wrong but one
thing it did triumphantly write we
actually passed the legislation in the
green deal to enable every home in this
country to cut it its energy use
dramatically and remember that we we are
as a country using more fuel more gas to
heat our homes than they do in Sweden
which let's face it is substantially
chillier because our homes are so leaky
are so inefficient that we have we are
potentially pushing at an open door but
the UK green deal home was strangled not
quite at Birth but pretty soon uh by the
treasure it was made over Complicated by
Whitehall which is a bureaucratic
problem and it was strangled by the
treasury saying no it shouldn't be
cheaper than if you actually go and get
it on your mortgage at home now if you
can get it on your mortgage at home why
would you do the green deal now if we'd
done that energy bills this coming
winter would be up to a third less than
they are going to be and That's a
classic case of getting uh
the long-term wrong at the expense of
the short term because at the time what
the treasury was arguing what George
Osborne and the conservatives were
arguing was that we couldn't afford to
do it it was going to add too much to
bills well tell that to people who are
now struggling with enormous increases
45 50 sometimes more in their energy
bills I think the real solutions are
going to be end up being bottom up
they're going to be local regions
figuring out to how to secure their
prosperity and Environmental Quality
it's going to be Innovations from
companies
may be seated with government funding
but I think
the real solutions are going to be
bottom up some International oversight
and bookkeeping sure why not but the
solutions aren't going to I mean well
you know when Greta says blah blah blah
you know I'm sympathetic because at the
end of the day all this exchange of hot
air you know it's not real solutions
which is right that um adaptation is
important and it's far far easier
politically because
um if um you spend money in a particular
Nation on adaptation
then of course the benefit accrues to
that country
whereas for mitigation coming down CO2
emissions then of course what we do
in one country has minimal effects I
mean we in in Britain produce about one
or two percent of the global CO2
emissions depending on how you count it
um and so even if we meet NetZero by
ourselves it makes
minimal difference to the world so in
order for mitigation to work
then one does need to have a consensus
and in particular the consensus has to
include the uh countries of the
developing World which may not now be a
missing as much as the global North but
if they develop to anything like the
standard living we have in the north
they will be dominating the emissions
and so
The crucial thing is to ensure that they
can LeapFrog to some technology which is
better than coal in all environmental
respects
[Music]
who do corporations listen to they
listen to their customers if we as
customers said we will not buy from you
unless you start meeting your carbon
targets and those carbon targets are
properly audited and scientifically
agreed to we will not buy from you we
will not work for for you until you do
that and we will only vote for
politicians who will Implement rules
that make that true
if that were the case corporations could
fix it I think much much faster than we
expect
even under the terrible sets of rules we
have now which Helen well described even
under those we now have renewable energy
cheaper than coal in more than half the
world no one thought that was possible
and how is that done that was done
through firms competing that was done
through a few leading firms saying we
must move everyone's moving too slowly
because everyone's in a box in
corporations so if you run a big cement
company you know cement's a disaster you
know there has to be another way they've
set up a Consortium across the industry
to try and really discover a new
technology they're making progress but
at the moment they have to respond to
their shareholders there's no regulation
I think many corporations are doing the
best they can in a regulatory regime
that is not sympathetic well I mean I
think a lot of this from the point of
view of first of all there is a there's
a lack of transparency at the moment and
the reason consumers can't make
decisions is partly is because of that
like transparency because some companies
have a huge amount of control over not
only the information about their thing
but about the narrative they've got good
PR companies we can see the oil
companies at the moment telling people
that uh you know they can buy offsets
they can just just take carbon out the
atmosphere that this is also about the
power in the system and you can't talk
about solving you know how the problems
of capitalism as you talk about the
problem of who how do you take that
power away from the current billionaires
because that completely can you know the
enormous amount of lobbying that is the
reason people buying things should make
a difference and it doesn't renewable
energy is cheaper but it isn't because
of this lobbying power but one one of
the issues with uh the way companies are
set up at the moment is that the risks
are all external right the companies
have there's an internal system a sort
of marketing you know you you do this
thing you can cause damage somewhere
else but you're not on the hook for that
damage it's society and the natural
environment that is on the hook for that
damage and that is one of the problems
with the way things are set up now is
that those the the damage you can't
close that cycle if you could make a
company completely responsible for
everything that happened all the way
down the line then maybe it would work
but at the moment they're responsible up
to this point and then they just cause
lots of damage that's distributed
throughout the world that's really hard
to see and they are not responsible for
that
up until now all of our increased
welfare increased output uh has been
largely driven by markets markets with a
certain number of constraints like for
example constraints on sulfur emissions
from Power stations and so forth
regulation but minor regulation
with climate change we've really got to
drive the system towards coming up with
Solutions where we don't have them and
there are a few in cement for example
really really crucial big emitter where
we need to come up with uh Solutions and
real economic incentives and that means
putting a carbon price
making that carbon price effective you
use getting there and it's getting good
and I'm delighted to say that the UK
post-brexit system is mirroring the EU
system although don't tell that to the
government uh so you know there are ways
of doing this but that's that driving
that process of change is absolutely
massively going to involve effectively
intervention in the market economy that
we haven't seen for a very long time
which is why so many people on the right
really don't like it they're not going
to do it so I mean the thing is we you
know people talk about cap and trade and
carbon taxes and all this and like you
know theoretically we got the price
right blah blah blah but what does the
price need to be it needs to be in the
hundreds of pounds you know per time it
needs to be in the thousands of pounds
per ton very soon and right now what is
it in most places you know in the EU
they had a cap and trade system and they
were trading like three Euros a ton
that's nothing right they could just
ignore it at that point there's a reason
why they're not raising it up to the
level that it needs to be at because
again you're competing against everyone
else in the World Market it's not going
to happen
um at the beginning I introduced a quote
from Mark Carney saying that really
climate change Net Zero is the greatest
commercial opportunity of our time do
you think that capitalism will fail to
capitalize on that opportunity I think
capitalism is very good at capitalizing
on things so if you set the question
right they would do it very well and my
fear is that
um our tools for setting the question
setting the question that really needs
to be asked are not the one that's most
convenient to the companies that already
exist what questions just you know what
couple of questions do you think would
be nice how do we live so we best fit in
with existing Earth Systems that's the
critical question the Earth is this
enormous complicated wonderful engine
that already does a huge amount of
things into already supporting our
civilization and we're kind of chipping
away at it what we need to do is ask
what it's doing and how we should fit in
with it not say what do we want and how
do we go poking and it's that humility
what are we missing the most in that the
materials use is a key example right
where we just assume there's this
one-way pipe that we take it and we put
it we've got this place we call away
we're just going to put it away there is
no way except out in our materials yeah
so the materials we use is that you have
to unless you like every single product
that is made should be made with using
recycled materials in its design like
built-in and it should be designed to be
recycled right from the start and if you
because the assumption has to be that we
are going to do what the Earth Systems
do which is everything is just going to
go round and round okay so that's the
sort of Regulation that you would need
in order to make capitalism work we must
operate this in the same way on using
the same basic principles the Earth's
natural cycles already use
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV